Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! this is going
to be my first Jessica Jones video so I'm
going to do a breakdown of her character and
her history in the comics they just announced
they're taking the a.k.a. out of the title
so if you never called it a.k.a. Jessica Jones
you were doing the right thing that was just
a working title it was meant to be a play
on the fictional company that she started
in the comics alias private investigations
the character was created by bandits to be
like like a stand-in for Jessica Drew is getting
his spider woman in this alias comic that
he was writing but it did didn't work out
in the planning stages so he had to create
an original character he someone who is kind
of a a washed up superhero to be a private
investigator investigating superheroes in
the context of the Netflix series that's essentially
what the characters going to be doing but
she she has this whole big history she's been
part of the avengers she has superpowers so
what we see in the TV show will be like a
small slice of her life like when she's at
her lowest the essence of her characters that
she's just constantly felt demoralized her
whole life got constantly felt like an outsider
so she just has no sense of self worth reading,
see with the arc of the series is right now
in the same vein as daredevil did during season
one of his show she's going to go you know
enough is enough job like a big called action
we can thank David tenant for that he's playing
a really nasty Marvel villain called the purple
man but rewind in time so Jessica Jones is
a character that you know because Bend is
created or relatively recently you know in
the last like 15 years he had direct con her
into the Marvel universe in this really big
way so historically she's crossed paths with
some of the biggest avengers but we've only
learned about it recently so it's it's a bit
weird in the comics so whenever she debuted
it in her first title in the alias comic she
was already working as a private investigator
her back stories told in flashbacks savannas
made it so that she originally went to the
same high schools Peter Parker they kinda
knew each other she was really shy she had
a crush on him when she was going up to finally
tell him is when he got bit by the spider
so she is a Gwen Stacy Mary Jane almost ran
in almost romance of Peter Parker's later
her father who worked for Stark industries
got two free passes to Disneyland from Tony
Stark himself on the way back from that trip
they got in the car accident with a military
convoy carrying radioactive chemicals so you
see, we got the standard Stan Lee radioactive
waste origin story you know with her superpowers
but she went into a coma her father died eventually
she was adopted by the Joneses that's where
she gets the Jones name went back to Midtown
high school and continued to be a normal teenager
they just happen to have superpowers all the
normal high school stuff happened to her Flash
Thompson pigs on her just like he picked on
Peter Parker who at this time had already
become Spider Man, Peter tried to get close
to her but she pushed him away remember that's
a common theme across her entire life she
just pushes people away eventually she sees
Peter fighting Sandman at their school and
is inspired to use her powers to help people
that's the beginning of the Jewel Jones era
she takes that name and tries to start fighting
crime she has limited invulnerability superstrength
and she can fly but not very well so she does
have legit powers but she just never got like
really amazing using them in her early years
she ends up running into Zebediah Killgrave
a daredevil villain that's the purple man
he uses his powers to take mental control
of her and make her commit crimes for him
his power is is that he gives off this pheromone
that gives him control of people he controlled
big crowds of people all the same time after
eight months of psychological torture in control
he finally censer on a mission to kill daredevil
she ends up at the avengers mansion Scarlet
Witch runs into her and breaks the psychic
cold she falls into a coma the avengers try
to help her Captain America ends up offering
her membership in the avengers but she pushes
him away to just because she's been so demoralized
member it is been eight months of constant
torture her big comeback came during the pulse
storyline where she takes the name the nitrous
inserted fighting crime again you can actually
read part of that story lot are Marvel unlimited
not not all of Jessica Jones's storylines
are Marvel Limited is kind of a pain in the
butt so during his time as the nitrous she
went up against the owl Leland Owlsley that's
this guy from the daredevil Netflix series
we actually saw him she ends up running into
and be-friending both Luke Cage and iron fist
they develop a friendship obviously she went
on to develop a romantic relationship with
Luke Cage later and they have they have a
baby together the cool thing about their baby
is is that she's named Danielle she's named
after iron fist Danny Rand she became Captain
America she's of this in vulnerable superstrong
Capain. America because she got both Luke
Cage's and Jessica Jones' powers but in present
day in the series she'still a baby so whenever
you see her Captain like some far future storyline
so later in her timeline Jessica Jones ended
up working at the daily bugle for little while
for J Jonah Jameson ended up quitting you
when he started going after the new avengers
eventually joined the new avengers and became
power woman it's is really vicious cycle with
her to know whereby shall be a superhero something
terrible will happen should get demoralized
and quit and eventually some some big called
actual happen and should become a superhero
again so her story is all about recognizing
your own self-worth in the context of the
Netflix series even even if she does become
fully actualized by the end I don't know she's
going to be wearing a costume or not she does
the comics she is like a number different
costumes but if you're in vulnerable and superstrong
there's not much reason to wear a costume
like daredevil wears a costume like Batman
wears a costume to scare the shit out of criminals
and to protect them from from bullets and
knives Luke cages a good example of someone
who does not need a super suit superstrong
super and vulnerable like I said they haven't
announced an official premier day but what
I think they might do is to is try and sink
it up with another big Disney are Marvel movie
the problem is is that the only other big
Marvel movie this year is Antman that's only
couple weeks away and it's possible that they're
still trying to finish Jessica Jones episodes
they have to finish all 13 before they can
drop him and a lot of you are asking about
the timeline because were getting like season
two of daredevil before we get Luke Cage and
it is getting a little bit wonky but it's
probably going to happen is is that the shows
will move in real time just like the Marvel
movies Jessica Jones whenever it starts will
pick up like eight months in the timeline
after the end of daredevil bullets can happen
is is will get Jessica Jones at the end of
this year that will get daredevil season to
write before Capt. America Civil War that
will probably get Luke Cage because they're
just starting preproduction on that right
now and then will probably get Jessica Jones
season to what about iron fist everyone wants
to know when iron fist is coming that's like
the last thing they do before they do the
defenders miniseries I would think were going
to see iron fist season one sometime at the
beginning or during 2017 who knows because
by that time will be on daredevil season three
hopefully Netflix will clarify some of this
is is they probably don't have specific dates
in mind for when they're going to drop stuff
it probably just depends on when they finished
making it a lot of you also asked your how
do these Netflix shows that Marvel is doing
make money in the answer is they don't make
money Netflix gets all of its money from subscribers
just like HBO so the only real benchmarks
that they have to measure whether or not it
shows popular is by how many people scream
it and by how much their subscriber base grows
whenever they premier the series all things
considered though all these Marvel series
super popular we will have multiple seasons
all the way up through avengers infinity war
so do not worry so it can happen is we get
closer to Jessica Jones I'll start doing more
videos for that serious you to be sure to
subscribe to get everything it is any other
you know Netflix related videos that you guys
want me to do just let me know the schedule
is a little wonky today so tomorrow I'll be
doing a new flash video new game of thrones
don't worry there's been a lot of Batman vs
Superman stuff too so if I feel like that's
exciting enough I'll make a video for it too,
while you wait for that stuff to post you
can click here to learn all about the punisher
joining daredevil season 2 really excited
about that and you can click here to learn
about Mirror Master joining the flash season
2 thank you so much for watching, everybody
High Five and I'll see you tomorrow!